In 2010, as part of their
tenth-anniversary celebrations,
Google awarded huge sums of money
to five projects,
small companies, startups and inventions
that they thought could change the world.
Those five included some names
that you might recognise:
the most famous is Khan Academy,
which was only a
couple of years old then.
But Google also gave
one million dollars
to an invention intended to
revolutionise public transit:
the Shweeb.
This was the prototype,
set up as a racetrack,
and it's still here
in New Zealand.
- Shweeb is effectively
a bicycle on a monorail.
These have been specifically
designed so that
they can swing horizontally,
we get up to speeds of about
60 kilometers an hour,
for someone that's
doing really well.
The original theme of this was to
turn them into a transport system.
The racetrack, in our environment,
is certainly better
because we're an adventure park.
If it was just a setup where we
would just cruise around the park,
we don't think it would've
had enough impact.
The electric sides of them
are off-the-shelf.
Everything else is built
by us here in Rotorua.
The initial ones were built with
Geoff Barnett, the inventor,
when he first got the ride going.
They then adapted that
very quickly,
because there was a few
things that didn't work.
And then when there was
a change in management,
we made electric pedal assists.
There was the family market
that were dying to do it,
but they found it a bit too hard
to get them going.
2017-18 is when the
next generation,
the third generation
of pods came in.
[screaming]
Sorry about that.
- There are some obvious
drawbacks with the design.
What if the person in front
pedals slowly,
how do you overtake?
You can't.
The marketing copy for the
Shweeb says that instead,
you just make contact
with the car in front
and push it along too,
and build up a train
of these pods
moving along the track,
all working together.
How about uphills?
What if you get tired?
Or downhills, if you
need to brake?
Or what if you're approaching
a track switch
and it's not locked
into place yet?
Well, the marketing says that
in the final version,
there'd be electric boosters
available on uphills,
which, to be fair, there are
now in this version,
and also brakes on each pod,
and a control centre somewhere
to watch over traffic and safety.
Which adds such a ridiculous amount
of complexity and points of failure.
And their answer for "what if you're
wearing a skirt in this position" was:
"don't".
- It has to swing.
You would have too much tension
and torsion on the pods
if it stayed straight
as you were going this way.
So it is designed to swing,
and it's got dampeners
so that it takes up the
swinging motion and slows it down.
It's one of the rides here at
Velocity Valley that anybody can do,
from three years old,
right up to 90 years old.
- This is what transit nerds
call a "gadgetbahn":
something that looks and
sounds futuristic,
but is actually worse than a
more down-to-earth option.
Instead of this, cities could
just build separated bike lanes,
they'd handle more people,
reach further, cost far less,
require very little maintenance,
and allow overtaking.
It's pretty obvious that the Shweeb
was not the worldwide
future of public transit,
but somehow, out of 150,000 ideas,
Google looked at this and said,
yeah, spend a million dollars
on more studies
to see if it can get rolled out.
And the prototype was already
built at the time!
A lot of the media back then
were... skeptical.
- They had lots of opportunities.
Most people know about
the Google campus.
They also had the Olympics,
they had BP oil.
They had these big ones lined up,
but they just never came through.
And so we actually bought the IP and
everything off the original owners.
We've already got a franchise
started in Korea,
so we're gonna be working pretty hard
to get more on the go.
More as a ride experience.
We're still in that zone where
to turn it into a transport system
takes a lot of work.
But yeah, it's definitely something
that everybody asks us about.
- I will say, though: this is fun.
There is a sort of
retro-futuristic kick
in pedalling your own
monorail pod.
I did try to reach out to the
original inventor for comment,
because of course, that's good practice
for something like this,
but I coudn't even find
a way to contact him.
Please don't try,
if you're watching this?
Just... please don't. I'd guess
he wants to be left in peace,
hopefully you can
respect that as well.
Truth is, I don't know how I'd feel
if something I'd invented,
something that got a
million dollars in funding,
something that presumably
I'd had faith in
and worked on for years...
ended up being a strange
novelty ride for tourists.
But I do know
I'd be really annoyed
if people kept asking me about it.